can you uh tell me what you learned
hanging out with a herd of elephants
yeah what should uh what do people not
understand about elephants that's that's
beautiful to you that's interesting to
you first of all I think that elephants
should have government representation as
like a subset of society like actually
they they have intelligence they are so
intelligent and and when you look at an
elephant so there's this question that
keeps coming up of you know are we are
we smart enough to know how smart
animals are can can we can we interpret
the intelligence that we're seeing
and I've I've I've I lived with a
semi-wild herd of elephants in India for
a while and
some of the things that I saw like
changed how I view reality to be honest
with you because
you know you watch a matriarch of an
elephant herd walk up to someone that
none of us knew was pregnant
and her trunk goes to her stomach
and then she calls all the other ones
over and they're interested in this
little human that that they know that
there's something in there and they're
and they're all conversing about it and
you go whoa
or that every morning we'd wake up and
the elephants didn't want the stream
water they didn't want the lake water
they want puddles they wanted the water
from our well we had like a stone well
you know like a traditional and every
morning it's like run out of bed because
all the elephants were going to come and
they were going to rip the bucket off
and destroy everything but they wanted
that nice cold clean water
and so it was like caring for elephants
that were wild that were sometimes
getting shot at by Farmers because if
they went to try and Rob some bananas so
these are sort of like delinquent
elephants that were half Wild and the
forest Department was thinking about you
know getting rid of them which whatever
that meant
and uh
I made really good friends with this one
elephant his name was Dharma
and Dharma had the had the the stuff
doesn't this is It's hard to write the
book I'm writing right now because none
of it sounds real
he grew up around people because he was
a tuskless male so he couldn't hang out
with the females because he was a
grown-up male and he couldn't hang out
with the males the Bulls because he
couldn't defend himself when they
roughhoused and everything so Dharma
would be like wandering around the
forest not knowing who to hang out with
and so like there was one night there
was a tiger calling and we just heard
you could hear it echoing over the hills
and what does Dharma do 2 A.M we hear
Dharma show up and he's the same thing
he starts throwing a tantrum he starts
pulling over he says takes a chair
throws it
we had bananas in the truck Dharma walks
up to the truck it's like a Jeep he
walks up to the Jeep smells it he looks
at me and he's like you gonna get out of
bed I'm like no I'm not gonna get out of
bed I was like Dorma you're a grown ass
elephant the tiger does its thing again
and he's like I need bananas to feel
better yeah pushes the truck up on two
two wheels oh wow looks at me
is this how you want it to be so I'm up
I'm up and I go and I'm like please
please please please please don't make
me I'm rubbing his face and he's like he
puts it down he's like all right well
then then put it in hit me
I didn't do it so he lifts it up again
and so in the end there was no way for
me to outsmart the elephant he wins yeah
there's nothing I could do and so a lot
of my job was taking him out into the
forest and and you know spending a
little bit of time with him I have this
beautiful
one time I set up the tripod and I went
and I was just I was just journaling and
he would come and he would just like
play with my hair and he'd be like hey
what's up you know he just he wanted
someone to to interact with on an
emotional level
and you know when you think about
elephants in terms of the fact that you
know people go oh you know they
they use medication to induce labor it's
like yeah that's not that surprising
they they they hold the bones of the
dead it's like yeah they have the best
smell of pretty much any animal that's
also not surprising they probably know
exactly who that was that bone but they
can navigate to water holes and
communicate in ways that we cannot
really figure out and so when you hear
about people measuring out elephant
intelligence
you'll hear about scientists being like
oh well we gave it a you know a bucket
with a hole in it and then it had like a
key and there was a rope and you're like
bro this is all
human stuff yeah can you go walking with
them for three weeks in the wild and
watch how they deal with the problems
that they encounter in the forest
and so elephants have become especially
recently with the work that's been gone
that I've been doing in Africa with
betpaw
um I've just become so fascinated with
elephants and uh
you know
elephants the elephant the African
elephant population right now is down at
two percent of what it was a few hundred
years ago were really we're really
putting them on the brink of you know
there's some elephants that are being
born tuskless
because we've
poaching has taken down
the great tuskers to the point where now
it's it's actually beneficial for some
elephants and not have tusks because
anyone have humans but that's that's
like we've created deformed elephants
and so like now I'm
gotten very concerned with
issues of elephants and tusks of
fundamental to the interaction between
elephants absolutely I mean with males
compete with each other but also
elephants use their tusks you know like
they'll they'll break a branch and
they'll be like this is a good Branch
I'm going to eat the hell out of this
and they'll like hang it on their Tusk
and they'll like grab a bunch of other
stuff they'll like hold it
um you know ripping a tree up out of the
ground I just watched two weeks ago as
as I was watching an elephant he got
down on his knees and stuck his his Tusk
into the ground and like leveraged up he
like Archimedes to this root out of the
ground and then was like that's a sweet
root now when he left I went and I
tasted the root and it was like sweet
Ginger and I was like I have no idea
what this is but he knew it was good did
they use Tusk for sexual selection like
to impress the ladies or no it's
certainly involved in how who who has
mating rights oh who wins who wins I
mean if you got the big tusks and there
are elephants out there like the mammoth
big tuskers that have tusks down to the
ground like huge and when you see them
it's like seeing something unique on
Earth it's Unique in history because
we're at a point where we might lose
those there are only a few of them left
and then they're so prized by hunters
yeah it's interesting because I I forget
what the actual conclusion on that is
because there's some studies of the use
of the value of Beauty in evolution like
birds yeah and peacocks and so on that
there's no actual
value to it but it
plays a role in in sexual selection
meaning value like
it's much easier to understand
competition like a Tusk helps you defeat
sure the competitive tool but I bet you
there's a component to the Tusk where
the ladies go God damn that's a nice
like there's a visual beautiful
component maybe not I don't know but
what if what if beauty though as we're
defining it though is is is symmetry and
the the absence of yellow spots on your
face and and
healthy looking hair and so like I think
to us beauty is
sexually appealing traits that look good
to mate with and so so that that 19 year
old with Marissa everybody in the world
would swipe left on that yeah
at least it's like really desirable
object in the universe